it's been 15 years since international
badass and shirtless midlifecrisis
Vladimir Putin was first voted into
Russia's highest office but it's not all
pomp and circumstance Putin's time in
office whether as president or prime
minister hasn't been the best for
everyone if you're a good friend then
Congrats on the fruits of nepotism but
gay Ukrainian Chechens
living in the way of an Olympic venue
good luck with that so to honor the
Russian presidents 15th anniversary
Russia tonight broadcasted an award
ceremony unlike any other let's check
out some of the highlights
thank you welcome back this day is great
let us continue this next category is
best Russian literature and the nominees
are
Dostoyevsky for crime and punishment
Tolstoy for war and peace and Putin for
judo history theory and practice and the
winner is Vladimir Putin
ANSI winner for best competition to name
cute puppy for Prime Minister Putin is
president foodie
the award for shooting Siberian tiger
with a tranquilizer that also said a
television crew goes to bloody reward
for putting on most high-quality Winter
Olympic Games that was total sum of
value of every other Winter Olympic
Games ever put on all together I don't
need this
Vladimir Putin the award for
successfully restoring pride of Mother
Russia by alienating West expanding
territories quieting the scent and
locking up those who disagree with
Russian values and Vladimir Putin goes
to Vladimir Bobby finally Svetlana the
award for best opposition to Vladimir
Putin the nominees are Maurice Nemtsov
and the winner is
Maurice Nemtsov unfortunately bodies
could not be here today so a war will be
received by
congratulations neither can I please see
my family please you promise please it's
just yes you are a family
you